so let's uh let's let's talk about your
your campaign
yes you're you you became a republican
you said in 2009
yes what what about the republican party
did you feel like was a better fit for
you um i think
just the whole aspect of personal
responsibility like that's how i was
raised my father
uh was a disciplinarian that he also
says when you take personal
responsibility he says kim
this is the greatest country in the
world
right people are coming here because
of the opportunities here yeah when you
look at
and this is one of my things about black
lives matter but i won't go off on
attention
when you look at african immigrants that
come to this country
right they are black right by all
appearances there's a lot of them that
are very
black right and you're telling me black
lives matter people are saying
you're being pulled over because you're
black you're being stopped because
you're black
i have yet to see a hashtag nigerian
name
or hashtag name from like ghana
cameroon right you don't see names like
that hashtag
but they're by all appearances black so
obviously that doesn't did you did you
see that that nba story
where they were they they were striking
over the jacob blake thing
yahoo yahoo sports included this passage
where they said
some nba players have taken to
purchasing teslas because they believe
cops
won't expect a black man to be driving a
tesla and it was the most
ridiculous thing i heard because i'm
like dude just wanted to buy a tesla
right i don't think the cops are like a
tesla oh
there's probably a white guy driving
that car right so i'll just breaking the
law yeah i'll leave him alone
yeah in the middle of the hood tesla
actually i
i had a uh an interesting experience
when i was like uh
i think i was like 19. i met a guy from
haiti i worked with him at
o'hare airport and i didn't know him
very well but he said
he didn't like how in the u.s they try
and do all of these politically correct
terms for people like asian american
african-american
and he was like i'm from haiti he's like
i'm not an african-american
i'm haitian like don't call me that yeah
it's very
it's very weird how i think a lot of i
you know what man it's been more and
more ever since especially with black
lives matter that i've started to feel
like a lot of the racism we see is
actually driven by the democrats and the
progressive left absolutely
i know it's kind of cliche to say to
someone who's a republican and been a
republican for a long time but here i am
being like hey wait a minute
they're the ones saying things like
voter id is racist
right but uh actually yeah let's do this
let me ask your question your thoughts
on voter id what do you think
um so this is my my idea so you're
saying
because i'm black i can't get an id
to go vote if if that is
what you're saying that is racist to say
okay so you're basically saying that
black people
don't get their driver's license don't
have a state id aren't smart enough to
do it aren't smart enough to bring it
uh to go vote no almost for almost
everything you need an
id right this is again just like we see
with the mail in voting
right like i said all the balance math
it's it's about
you know a way they can be fraudulent in
the process it has nothing to do but
they love to use us
as like the sa oh wait a minute let's
think about the blacks
can they can they rise to the occasion i
don't know
let's put the brakes on this but you
know but it's always and
i i hate to say it but it's a lot of
times it's white
officials that are saying that blacks
can't handle it
you know when do we get the microphone
and tell you what we can handle
did you see that ami horowitz video i
did not he went to
berkeley and he asked a bunch of white
college students
how do they feel about voter id and they
all said it's racist
i saw this video yes yes i did and it is
one of the funniest videos
for me uh again like i didn't i didn't
grow up in a black area
um i grew up in a relatively mixed poor
area but it still kind of resonated to
me to see regular people
understanding i'll put it this way i
hate elitism
and the this progressive racism
is like the epitome of ivory tower
elites they think they're better
if you look at the data that these
progressives tend to be
uh wealthy college-educated white people
yes and they think they're smarter than
everybody
and they think they're the saviors of
all these poor races but in reality
that mentality is them thinking they're
superior to other races
so when i see that video and my favorite
part of it is when
uh ami horowitz asks this like
middle-aged black dude you know where
the dmv is at he goes oh yeah it's over
on 25th street
as if he's giving directions like of
course he knows where the dmv is
yeah do you know anybody who doesn't
have an id i don't but this is
you know i don't know if a lot of people
have seen that video of candace owens in
front of congress
um and i think jim jordan was asking
questions
and there were three white women telling
her
how oppressed black people are i
remember that
yes she had on the blue blazer and she's
like that's interesting i've been black
my entire life
and i am not feeling oppressed today but
i'm so glad these three white women are
telling me this
isn't isn't candace kind of like isn't
she rich like i'm assuming she's very
successful
yeah i mean i would think so um
you know i even if she isn't rich she's
not oppressed
right yeah and you know it's amazing to
me but again this is what we see all the
time
you know if people actually look at the
crowd and some of these black lives
matter
um protests or riots a lot of times
it's white people yeah oh totally with
the black lives matter shirts on
and i'm like well where are the black
people you know i heard a story out of
i think it was portland where a woman
was like yelling at protesters where are
the black people at
because it was a bunch of white people
riding and acting a fool and she was
like what is this
like what are you people doing there's
you're not there there's actually a
bunch of videos like this though there's
one video where
black women stop antifa from trying to
graffiti and start fires
and it's crazy in one of them there's
like this white woman spray painting
and two black women are like stop
bringing that stuff to our neighborhood
and the white women actually say to the
black woman no no it's okay we're
helping you and we're like we're
fighting for you and it's like dude
you're destroying
their neighborhood you're not helping
them at all right it is
it is this do you uh you i bring this up
a lot i have to though but
you know about what's going on with
repeal prop 209 in california
somewhat it's the democrats wanting to
repeal the civil rights uh provisions in
their constitution
how is am i just naive or is
the democrats opposing civil rights and
they're
pushing racist policies and they think
many of them not all of them but they
think they're
superior and they're the saviors and all
that stuff yeah no you're absolutely
right and
if you take a good look at and this is
why i think we're always being divided
into these little boxes
you know like he would your friend was
saying the asian americans the
african-americans even though he was
haitian
it's almost as if we're now pushing
segregation
you know i think we definitely are and
it's like what are we doing
what are we doing we're rolling back so
much
of what we fought for and if civil
rights leaders were alive today like dr
martin luther king jr
who was telling people don't judge me
based on my color on my skin but the
content of my character
that's the opposite of what we're doing
today have you seen that book from
ibrahim abraham is it abraham or ibrahim
i-b-r-a-m ibrahim uh have you heard of
it have you heard of him he's got one of
the top books
in uh anti-racism there's a book he
wrote called how to be anti-racist
okay there's a passage that says uh the
only
he said something like if discrimination
is creating
racist uh equity then it is racist if
it's creating
uh or if it's creating inequity it's
racist if it's creating equity it's
anti-racist therefore
the only solution to past discrimination
is present discrimination
and the only solution to present
discrimination is future discrimination
wow quite literally saying we must
discriminate based on race
so when i see that that book is a top is
a bestseller and then you look
at like white fragility and there's many
other books in a similar vein
and it's not just why people who write
it it's it's also black people it's also
you know it's people of all races
you see oprah winfrey picks i mean
they're they're straight up saying we
got to be racist
yeah but they're trying to change the
definition of racist
so that like i i guess it it seems like
a certain point some these people
realized
we don't like racism we want to be just
friends and hang out
and break bread and you know stand by
the water cooler talking about what we
like
and they realized that if they were
going to bring back segregation and
discrimination
they had to alter the definition of
racism and so that's what they've done
yeah now it means prejudice plus power
and
you have to have institutional authority
or something like that
so now when they write books quite
literally saying that for one they are
avowed racists
like you've heard of white fragility the
woman straight up says she's
uncomfortable like if she walked into a
room full of black people
that's that's crazy to me right and then
she's gonna start
essentially lecturing everyone else on
what on their behavior and people adopt
this
so for me having grown up uh
i'll put it this way i grew up pretty
lefty when i was younger became kind of
just like
around the obama time i was like more of
a moderate still kind of progressive
and uh voted for obama the first time
and i'll tell you for me
when i snapped it was like literally a
month later when he drone-bombed a
village of women and children and i was
like
yeah like so much for that i guess and i
tried to be optimistic like maybe he's
got to wind things down
because he just came in and no no
no no so so for me that was like i'm out
but i think there's a lot of people who
have always been outside
of the democratic party and have viewed
them as always racist because their
history was racist
yeah and so i don't i don't know what
happened in that period after civil
rights
up until whatever's going on now but it
definitely feels like they're going
backwards they're rewinding the clock
towards segregation we just had that
story out of a university of michigan
dearborn where they created a non-poc
cafe which was a you you
stop knock it not kidding not because we
were joking they apolo they they didn't
they they they fake apologize for it
like they have so basically
they did a poc cafe they're not physical
spaces okay first
clarified okay they were like digital uh
digital roundtables and they had one
just for
they said non-poc i think we know what
that means the white people
and they said it's facilitated by a
white person for but it's facilitated by
non-poc
with non-poc to talk about their non-poc
feelings and community
and then they had the poc one and i'm
just like yo
[Laughter]
right is that where we're going wait so
when did they meet and hear about each
other's feelings
i don't know if it happened they they
issued an apology for the terminology
they used
they said we're so sorry about the terms
we use to describe our
cafe a productive situation seriously
i mean this is awful and you know what
really kills me i love when um
liberals get really upset when they say
oh someone's racist
and then that said person is racist or
that they're claiming is racist then
says well i'm not racist i have black
friends
and they're gonna say oh that's just a
racist thing to say i'm like
no it's not okay racists don't have
black friends
right like they don't they don't and so
you know it's now it's like just attack
everybody
and anybody that is not a person of
color
and tell them basically they are racist
and
they harbor these inner racist feelings
and now they're just now coming out
because president trump is now the
president yeah what has candice owen
said that that makes her a white
supremacist in their eyes
i don't know not i mean look even
even if like no i can't i can't even say
it
she doesn't talk about anything
pertaining to white people in
that regard like she's not talk she
talks about responsibility conservatism
the black family
right i'm like what where where where in
that is race where in that is her
supporting whiteness or whatever yeah i
guess when you look at
the the weird definitions if you if
you've seen like there was something um
it was in the smithsonian what was it it
was like the the
um national museum of african-american
history or something
okay have you seen this chart where they
explain what whiteness is i think i did
see this
yes man truly amazing this is this is
really a huge smack in the face for me
being like i can i still consider myself
to be a liberal i just don't think the
democratic party represents
what i you know what i look for anymore
it says it said
hard work is white is is a trait of
whiteness oh yeah
oh i saw that are you nuts yes and then
being on time wasn't it
yes being yes being on time
it's like wow i mean it's it's sad
i don't know where we're going but you
know this is why i'm glad i'm running
for office
and uh i hope more people that
feel like we're going in a dangerous
situation uh run for office as well
um i always consider myself because i've
had a non-profit for eight years
fiscally conservative socially liberal
yeah how do you so can you tell me a
little bit about your
non-profit about your um efforts there
because that was really interesting to
me
thank you um so i started it basically i
was working at a hotel in georgetown
university
hotel conference center i moved to
baltimore about 10 years ago when i met
my husband right now at that point
fiance
and the commute was a long commute two
hours one way he's like just stay home
you know um but you know you can only do
so many loads of laundry where you're
just like okay you know i'm smarter than
this
you know not to say it's a bad thing but
i wasn't even taking care of any kids i
was just sitting there
at home so i wanted to start a um
a non-profit to help young women that
might have had
um traumatic life experiences but were
overcoming and doing well
very good and so i decided to help these
young women with prom
and um these are girls that basically
had good grades
had a plan after high school whether it
was college or going straight to work
you know that couldn't afford prom and
so
i would collect prom dresses i took all
these prom dresses into this high school
and the girls are like looking at the
dresses and they're like oh my god
and i'm like yes i got so many right
they're like
no are these from 1982 where did you get
these dresses
and i'm like okay you've got a point
there so we actually took those dresses
we sold them
on ebay and with that money we actually
bought them dresses and then we were
able to spend money on their hair and
their makeup
and they had like these whole makeovers
and it was awesome um but when i went to
one of the prom send-off parties
one of the moms uh came to me and she
was like you know
i wish i could offer you something to
eat you know she's like you come and
sit down in their living room there was
uh like lawn chairs for
their furniture and you know i know this
young woman would tell me
all the time how their electricity was
on and off and she was sometimes doing
her homework by candlelight
yes and so i'm talking to the mom and
she was like i would love to go back to
work i just don't know how to do it
and then a light bulb comes on right and
you're like oh wait a minute kim
if you get parents you know back to work
of course they can afford prom and
everything else so i
i totally switched gears after the first
year um
and i started helping women coming out
of incarceration rehabilitation
and homelessness through nonprofits that
already existed
their employment specialist would call
us and say hey can you get her ready for
a job interview by tuesday
and so we were still collecting these
donated clothing and then just set up
selling them on ebay and we would give
them entire makeovers
wow that's so sweet yeah so we can wow a
lot this episode
over 200 women become gainfully employed
30 went on to be financially independent
but that's
to me the only way you're gonna lift
anyone out of poverty is with employment
and so i think people need to understand
that you know and
um you know that's why that's you know a
major part of my platform
is people becoming independent so yes
to me that's like that's really unusual
because it's so
consistent between what you say about
wanting people to take personal
responsibility
and your you know your non-profit and
getting these girls to take
responsibility and rewarding them for
doing so and then doing the same with
women who wanted to go back to work
i think that's a wonderful thread to
carry through thank you thank you it's
it's
and it's so simple right so we didn't
get any funding we didn't get any grant
money we didn't get anything
yeah um we were just like all right how
do we make money
ebay yeah you know and it's just
literally just taking a regular
idea and saying all right this is how we
gotta you know tackle the issue
but this is what's crazy about it like
i'm a college dropout myself
i didn't finish it wasn't for me i
dropped out but here we have these
politicians that with all these degrees
and they supposedly know all this stuff
right and they could come up with these
innovative ideas yet
no one seems to be able to tackle the
situation that we see
in the inner cities and it's like well
are you really the smart guy i think
you're smart enough to do it
you just don't want to do it and that's
where i have the issue
dependency yeah if you had a bunch of
free thinking
independent people they wouldn't want to
vote for you and they want guaranteed
votes
if you were stuck on benefits and i've
i've i know people who have gone through
this
where it's very difficult to get off the
cycle yes then
you're going to keep voting for the
person who says don't worry i'll keep it
coming right
that's a bummer it is a bummer and this
is why
you know i really started doing some
research and i don't know if people are
familiar with deron smith he works with
the trump administration he helped with
prison reform and
the first step act and you know everyone
says oh he's that one black guy that
works at the white house in the west
wing
he's not the only black guy he's just
like the one with the biggest position
over there but
you know he talks about how you know
you've got
section 8 right section 8 housing
vouchers
with those vouchers it came with
basically having the man
leave the home so the women could get
them and that's still how it is today
that's awful
but then you know he said i started
thinking like you know if you've got
section 8 is there a section 1 2 3 4 5 6
7
and so he looked it up and you know
we're looking at it section three
this is the same thing as section eight
but the dad can stay
in the home wow that's crazy so why on
earth and this is one of those things i
talked about with richard fowler
if you could change the policies right
to make things a little bit better in
the black community
like joe biden supposedly wants to do 50
years later why not replace section 8
with section 3.
if if that's where you want people to be
dependent and then to me that brings in
what two incomes in the household you
know then you're weaning people off of
it
the father's still in the home you've
got the family structure piece
why did we go with section eight over
section three
do you see the black lives matter
mission statement uh how they want to
dismantle
the family disrupt the nuclear family
structure or something that effect
yeah why would they want to do that
we've we know we've looked at a bunch of
studies and right now some of the data
i've read says
they don't they don't know necessarily
if it's
a father and a mother or just two
parents in general it might just be as
simple as two parents
because you have double income and you
have someone to be with the kid and you
know
but regardless the data shows that uh
two parents
a traditional family structure or
however as long as it ends up with the
parents
you know being able to raise their kid
they they prosper right and in single
parent households they they struggle
right or they're more likely to i should
say no not a guarantee
right why would you actively try to
encourage that right
the only thing i can think of is there
aren't actually black people
writing the mission statement for black
lives matter i wouldn't be surprised
that's the only
thing i can think of because if you are
black you know
what is it about 70 uh black children
are living in a single mother household
we know which friends uh became
successful and which ones didn't
and we know what their childhood was
like
um you know that's not news to us they
do have that data down right
but we know that just based on how we
grew up and who we grew up around
so it makes no sense so let me uh let's
go let's go to some policy stuff you've
got policies on your site what do you
want to do
what's your what's your first one what's
your pipe dream what's your pie in the
sky if you get
when you get elected yes you've got some
things you want to do
absolutely so first and foremost like i
said i talk about employment right
but not just jobs right we're always
talking about raising a minimum wage
what about careers right some real good
salaries with benefits um as we saw with
the lockdown we relied on other
countries for ppe
why not bring that billion dollar
medical equipment industry
right back to america right that would
bring back this these
you know we were a manufacturing
powerhouse at one point in baltimore
we have the second largest busiest port
at one point
uh right there in baltimore city right
our our port
is the same size as a port in
connecticut where they've got the
submarines
you know they've got the the windmills
all the jobs right
they've got so much going on there we
have the same exact size
and we've got what two cruise ships
coming in a week
going back out we're not utilizing at
all um so this is what i talk about a
lot this is what i talk about with duron
uh over at the white house and this is
why president trump tweeted
you know kimberly klasik will bring it
back and bring it back fast because he
knows that we've been having these
conversations
um opportunity zones a big deal
the trump administration the past four
years has taken 75 billion
and invested in opportunity zones in
these democrat cities that have been
just left neglected
what's interesting about it is when you
look at the opportunity zone map in
baltimore city
you will see that the neighborhoods that
i was walking in in my videos sandtown
easterwood
carrollton ridge those
areas were left out of the map
and what's interesting about is my
opponent writes this op-ed
saying it was president trump but he did
not he didn't do the opportunity zone
map
that was left up to local leaders right
but but people believe that because they
don't do their research and see
you know who wrote this map and so
anyway so i actually took some community
leaders in january
down to the white house to meet with
geron and talk about what they can do
when i posted that picture not too long
ago
um you know we had something back in the
day i think it was called empowerment
zones
uh which is similar and i actually got a
lot of crap from uh some republicans on
twitter
because i said you know we had something
similar it didn't really work because we
gave local leaders way too much power
and control
i said if we do opportunity zones right
in baltimore city
we're gonna have to do a carve out
because our local officials are way too
corrupt
and we're gonna be in the same situation
just because i said
i like trump's opportunity zones but i'm
gonna request a carve out
i got a phone call from black voices
from trump
and they said how dare you say that i
was like
dude what no look at baltimore look at
our history
bill clinton did the same thing with
empowerment zones it didn't work
local officials got involved right so
anyways they weren't happy about that
but i did go down and i talked to drawn
about it you know we were looking at it
and he goes you know what you're right
you're right there needs to be a carve
out or we need to change the structure
here
so that's my big push as we know there
is a trucker shortage across this
country
um i know you know eventually it you
know technology will probably give us
what
trucks that drive themselves the drones
are dropping off boxes
but we're not at that point yet and we
have a lot of people
in the area um that could benefit from
going to that
cdl six-week program to get their
license
yeah and we you know the six weeks two
thousand dollars
per person we are supposedly getting 1.1
billion dollars a year
i don't know where it is someone's
pockets are lined with gold
exactly but you know when i talk to
people in the area they say you know
that would be great
we would love to do something like that
and that's an easy class there's uh
nonprofits maryland new directions
there's all these people that actually
do the behind the wheel training all
states involved in it
six weeks six weeks we can get someone
you know these trucker positions
you know we've got amazon right there in
baltimore too
and you know i would hope that we would
offer them more warehouse spaces that we
could actually do this
even even if we get these self-driving
trucks we need local drivers
because the self-driving trucks stop
outside the cities and then you need a
driver to bring them in
right so that'd be that would be that
could be huge yeah good point there tim
and then of course education i'm talking
about school choice
so this is uh the easiest way to
i've been able to explain it where
people are able to digest it
i say look you know your schools are not
that great in this area
right sometimes schools need a little
competition right we do have some
charter schools and they do great
um but i say just think
if you say you know your kid has always
wanted to run track and you think they'd
be really good at it
just think if you could send your child
to a school with an actual track team
just think if you could send your child
to a school with a golf team or a swim
team and you know that they would excel
at this and they're like yes
i want that opportunity for my child i
mean look at look at the way the college
system is set up with minority
scholarships
you know my stepson he wanted to play
golf um you know
like yes go play right you know here is
a black american wanting to play golf
and he was good
you know go get those offers go get the
scholarships those opportunities exist
they're already there
so there's things that you can do and
that's how i really explain
school choice i mean we got to do some
education system anyways um
baltimore city uh ceo the public school
ceo
sonya sanchez makes 350 000 a year
and we've got so many kids exactly oh my
gosh
exactly you know the administrators make
a ton of money
yet the kids still graduate i'm able to
read write or do basic math
so that's a problem thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time